good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is turn your wounds into wisdom over to
you Oprah Winfrey turn your wounds into
wisdom you will be wounded many times in
your life you'll make mistakes some
people will call them failures but I
have learned that failure is really
God's Way of saying excuse me you're
moving in the wrong direction it's just
an experience doesn't experience just an
experience I remember being taken off
the air in Baltimore being told that I
was no longer being fit for television
and that I could not anchor the news
because I used to go out on the stories
and my own truth was even though I'm not
a weeper I would cry for the people in
the stories and which really wasn't very
effective as a news reporter to be
covering a fire and crying because the
people lost a house and it wasn't until
they I was demoted as a on-air
anchorwoman and thrown into the
talk-show
arena to get rid of me that I allowed my
own truth to come through and the first
day I was on the air doing my first talk
show back in 1978 it felt like breathing
which is what your true passion should
feel like it should be so natural to you
and so I took what had been a mistake
what had been perceived as a failure
with my career as an anchorwoman in the
news business and turned it into a
talk-show career that's done okay for me
your wounds and your failures will teach
you some of the most important lessons
that you will ever learn in life if you
are willing to listen to them instead of
complaining about them what often
happens when we have a feeling when we
have a setback when things don't go our
way instead of trying to learn for them
and say how can I do better what can I
learn from this so that the next time it
doesn't happen again
we often shut down we often say well
that didn't work out and so this sucks
and it's this person's fault and I'm
never gonna be a success you start
blaming other people and start
complaining instead of taking
responsibility insane what can I learn
from this how can I make this better and
quite often from the lowest lows that
you'll have ever in your life come the
highest highs because you've changed
because you've grown because you've
broken the mold because you've you're
that Phoenix rising now and you see that
over and over and over again in success
stories their greatest heights came as a
result of some deep dark place and so
don't stay down in that hole use that as
leverage to learn and grow into
something new
grow into that better version of
yourself if I think about all the big
failures that I've had in my life it's
always led to one of the most important
lessons that I've used for the rest of
my life and so as an example when I was
afraid to ask this girl out in Paris
that led me to not having any more
regrets that led me to live a life of
not having regrets because I don't want
to feel that pain of wondering what if
again when I told my business partner
that I quit on him when it was too
difficult to challenge and I said I quit
I'm done I want to feel valuable the
next day I woke up and said I had to
keep going and how do I do it by
modeling success when I lost out on a 40
million dollar deal when I was 22 years
old I realized that I needed to stop
being a perfectionist and start getting
work done and so those three lessons I
learned early in my life 18 19 and 22
I'm though 37 and those are still the
lessons that that are the most important
to me I still try to live a life of no
regrets whenever I don't know how to
solve a problem I always look at how can
i model success and it's a big part of
what this youtube channel is about and I
stopped trying to be a perfectionist and
just get stuff out there because
otherwise nothing happens and so if you
are in that deep dark place if you've
had some major setbacks and major
failures try not to let it be permanent
you know it's only a real failure if you
let that define you if you let that be
the point where you say I can never go
on and do more than this because I tried
once and it didn't work out
whenever you fail just ask yourself what
can I learn from this to be stronger and
if you can adopt that mentality then
you'll be doing what the most successful
people do in the world they turn that
rejection and they turn that failure and
turn that fear and they create amazing
things as a result so the question of
the day today is I'm curious what was
one of your biggest failures and what
did you learn from that to grow stronger
leave it on the comments below I'm
really curious to see what you have to
say I also want to give a quick shout
Atul na I hope I pronounced that ok
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word I really really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoyed the read thank you guys again
for watching I hope you have an amazing
day I believe in you I hope we continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of an espresso
[Music]
with respect to failure it's terrible
but but but necessary if you if you are
going to try something hard if you're
putting yourself out there in some way
there are going to be times where you
screw up or you don't succeed or there
are times where you do everything right
and you still don't succeed but that's
not just true of politics or running a
non-for-profit that's true some of you
talked about being entrepreneurial if
you're starting a clothing line that's
that's a cutthroat business it yeah I'm
sure you yeah I have every confidence I
out of it you're gonna succeed at some
point but you'll go through some
failures you know and and I think that
the most important thing and and this is
a little bit of a cliche but sometimes
clichés are true is to learn from those
failures and to have a sense of
resilience and be able to examine what
is it that I did not succeed at why
didn't I succeed and what do I need to
do better that's with respect to the
failure issue if you're focused on
giving of yourself to accomplish
something then even when you fail at a
particular objective you're still
succeeding in learning about how you can
accomplish those goals I read this quote
hum during in knodel an obituary for
Floyd Patterson the boxer and he cert
said he only learned
from losing a fight he said you don't go
and watch video from when you win you
watch video from when you lose and it is
the failures that build the character
that make you smarter stronger tougher I
always told people were scarred but
smarter and I think that is a really
good thing to be you can build on all of
that accumulated knowledge in a way that
can serve you and your clients or your
company very very well but there have
been you know numerous moments of great
pause and reflection where I've set and
say and I say to our team and I say to
myself what is the universe trying to
teach me what do you do when you start a
business but it fails well hopefully you
can learn from all the mistakes all the
good things and all the bad things and
reapply it to your new business or
reapply it to your new job or your new
career destination look at Apple Apple
is one of the most prestigious bankable
companies in the world and they had a
lot of failures they had a lot of
launches that didn't work they had a lot
of things that just didn't click with
the audience and their customers but
that didn't stop them from having a
thriving business you learn way more
when you fail then when you succeed
that's something I can guarantee you on